[موسيقى]
مساء الخير الحدث الابرز على الساحه هذه
الايام طبعا زياره الرئيس الصيني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اللي يعقد فيها
ثلاث قمم لقاء مع القائد السعوديين لقاء
مع القاده الخليجيين لقاء مع عدد اكبر من
القاده العرب
هذه الزياره بتطرح مجموعه كبيره من
الاسئله كثير منها سوف يتم طرحه بصوره
افضل بعد انتهاء الزياره لكن قبل الزياره
واثناء الزياره وبعد الزياره في اسئله
مطروحه دائمه السؤال الاولاني ماذا يريد
الرئيس الصيني من الدول العربيه وماذا
تريد الدول العربيه من الرئيس الصيني
والسؤال الثاني بطبيعه الحال كيف تؤثر هذه
الزياره او ماذا تعني هذه الزياره
للولايات المتحده
للاجابه على السؤال الاولاني ماذا يريد
الرئيس الصيني من العرب وماذا يريد العرب
من الرئيس الصيني وطبعا ممكن وسع السؤال
في حقيقه الامر ماذا يريد الرئيس الصيني
من منطقه الشرق الاوسط لانها بتتسع لما هو
اكثر من العرب ايران تركيا الى اخره
الاجابه المختصره جدا جدا هو انه عشان
نفهم الرئيس الصيني عاوز ايه من المنطقه
لازم نفهم ايه اهم اولويات الصين الان
الاولويه العاجله جدا للصين في سياساتها
الخارجيه هو الحفاظ على مستويات نمو
مرتفعه يعني تحقق تنميه اقتصاديه مضطرده
بشكل مستمر 5% 6% لو امكن اكثر يكون افضل
ليه تحقيق تنميه اقتصاديه اولويه قصوى
للصين ببساطه لانه لا شيء يمكن ان يتحقق
بالنسبه للصينيين بدون هذه التنميه تحقيق
تنميه اقتصاديه مستمره وبشكل كبير مهم لكل
الدول لكن بيبقى اهم الدول اكثر من دول
اخرى يعني بالنسبه للصين اذا اللي هي
عددها حوالي مليار و400 مليون نسمه اذا لم
يستطع ان يستمر في تحقيق معدلات النمو
مستمره معناه انه لا حديث عن الصين العظمى
او القرن الصيني والتفوق الصيني وتربع
الصيني على عرش يعني قياده العالم لن يكون
هناك اصلا استقرار سياسي في الصين لانه لا
يوجد استقرار في دوله لا تطعم افواه
الفقراء كم يبلغ عدد الفقراء في الصين
ارقام متباينه حسب المعايير لكن واحد من
المعايير السائده في الحساب انه بيعتبره
ان الصين دوله ذات دخل متوسط عالي
وبالتالي معيار الفقر فيها انه كل واحد
بيعيش على خمسه ونصف دولار في اليوم
بالنسبه للدول الفقيره اقل من اثنين دولار
في اليوم بالمعيار ده في اكثر من 200
مليون صيني تحت خط الفقر لابد من اطعام
افواههم وفي طبقه متوسطه كبيره في الصين
عددها حوالي قد ايه حوالي 400 مليون صيني
الطبقه المتوسطه تريد ما هو اكثر من اطعام
افواههم تريد رعايه صحيه تريد تعليم افضل
تريد حياه اكثر همم رفاهيه يعني كل هذا لن
يتحقق بدون الاستمرار في معدلات النمو
الاقتصاديه طيب تحقيق معدل نمو اقتصادي
بالنسبه لبلد مثل الصين مليار و400 مليون
يتطلب امرين
الحصول على اكبر كم ممكن من المواد الخام
وعلى راسها طبعا البترول والغاز لتشغيل
الاله الانتاجيه الاكبر في العالم
ثم
اسواق تبيع فيها هذه المنتجات
منطقه الشرق الاوسط بتوفر الاثنين بالنسبه
للصين توفر لها المنتجات الخام المواد
الخام اللي الصين بتاكلها وتستهلكها
بشراسه كل انواع المواد الخام وعلى راسها
طبعا البترول والغاز خصوصا من دول الخليج
تذهب يذهب البترول والغاز الى الصين الصين
بتشغل بالماكينه الضخمه لجهازها الانتاجي
الجهاز الانتاجي في النهايه اييي
بينتج منتجات نهائيه في شكل اجهزه
كهربائيه ملابس احذيه
ماكينات كل انواع المنتجات يبحث عن اسواق
الدول المنطقه بترحب بشراء هذه المنتجات
في هذا عظيم جدا بالنسبه الصين على الجانب
الاخر ماذا تريد دول العربيه اهم اولويات
الدول العربيه وتحديدا دول الخليج دول
العربيه عاوزه من الصين كل شيء كل شيء لكن
في اولويات
الاولويه الاولى للدول العربيه وتحديدا
الدول الخليجيه هو مساعدته على الانتقال
من اقتصاد الطاقه الاقتصاد متنوع دول
الخليج
ما زالت تعتمد بشكل كبير على عوائدها من
البترول والغاز الاولويه الاولى ليها
الملحها لكل صانع قرار في دول الخليج هو
الانتقال من الاعتماد على الطاقه الى
اقتصاد متنوع علشان دول الخليج تنتقل من
اقتصاد الطاقه الاقتصاد متنوع وطبعا بديهي
دي اولويه دول الخليج لانه هم يدركونا ان
اسعار البترول والغاز ان ارتفعت او انخفضت
لن تدوم طويلا 20 25 30 40 سنه لن تدوم
طويله
وعليه فالامل ان احنا ان هم يكونوا الدول
عندها اقتصاد متنوع الاقتصاد المتنوع
يحتاج الى امرين
الامر الاول انه يحتاج الى تمويل علشان
يمول طموحاته في تنويع اقتصاداته وتبقى
اقتصادات خدميه
وصناعيه وزراعيه لو امكن الى اخره محتاج
تمويل ضخم
ويحتاج العامل الثاني انه هاو الخبرات
المعرفه التكنولوجيا اللي هتساعده لتنويع
اقتصاداته الصين بتقدم له الاثنين ازاي ما
هي الصين اكبر مستهلك للبترول والغاز الذي
يخرج من دول الخليج وبالتالي
الدول الخليج بتابع بتبيع للصيد البترول
والغاز والمواد الخام الاخرى وتحصل على
نقط هذا النقد بتستخدمه او ترغب في
استخدامه في تنويع اقتصاداتها لما تيجي ت
اقتصادتها تحتاج الى تكنولوجيا ومعرفه
علشان تعمل بنيه تحتيه متطوره نترات موانئ
طرق شركات اتصالات شبكات انترنت متقدمه
تحتاج الى مدن ذكيه تحتاج الى كل شيء
الصين قادره على ان تقدم كل هذه
الاحتياجات
بكفاءه وباسعار رخيصه وبشروط مقبوله طيب
ما الغرب عنده ايضا امكانيات وقدرات
تكنولوجيه بس هناك فرقين الفرق الاول انا
لسه قايله ان الصين عندها استعداد ان
تشارك الدول الصديقه لها في هذه
التكنولوجيا بشروط مقبوله على عكس
الولايات المتحده وشركائها اللي بيضعوا
شروط احيانا بتكون تعجيزيه يعني مثلا اذا
اردت ان تحصل على هذه التكنولوجيا عليك
مثلا بالتطبيع مع اسرائيل مثلا اذا اردت
هذه التكنولوجيا عليك ان تغير قوانينك
بحيث انها تتفق مع مطالب الولايات المتحده
اذا اردت هذه التكنولوجيا فعليك فعليك
فعليك الى اخره الصين لا تفرض كل هذه
الشروط طبعا عندها بعض التصوراتها زي اي
دوله لكن شروطها اقل بكثير جدا هي عاوزه
تعمل بزنس في هذه المرحله فقط لا غيرك لكن
في امر ثاني انه الصين كان فيما مضى من
السنوات بتقدم تكنولوجيا اقل من تكنولوجيا
الغرب ثم اصبحت لديها التكنولوجيا
تماثل التكنولوجيا الغربيه ثم اصبحت الان
لديها تكنولوجيا اكثر تفوقا في كثير من
الجوارب من التكنولوجيا الغربيه مين اللي
بيقول الكلام ده اكثر من مركز واكثر من
جامعه محترمه في
الغرب نفسه يعني مثلا من عده ايام قليله
مركز بلفر للعلوم والعلاقات الدوليه
التابع لجامعه هارفرت اصدر تقييما وتقريرا
بيقول في انه
الصين بالفعل حلت محل الولايات المتحده
كاكبر منتج للتكنولوجيات المتقدمه او اللي
بيسموها التكنولوجيه المستقبل
وما هي التكنولوجيات المستقبل
اول شيء طبعا
الذكاء الصناعي
الكوانتم انفورميشن ساينس
الشرائح او السيليكون
داكترسى الطاقه الخضراء الصين يعني تفوقت
فيها بشكل كبير الى اخره
او مركز بالفرع التابع لحرف رد يا ابني
على هذه النتيجه مادام الصين تفوقت في
علوم المستقبل
وتتجاوز الولايات المتحده اقتصاديا خلال
عشره سنوات جدا
طب امثله هل الكلام ده يعني ممكن الصين
تطلبه من الدول العربيه وممكن الدول
العربيه تنتظره من الصين في السنوات
المقبله دي شراكه بدات بالفعل من سنين
بينما كان الغرب غافلا بينما كانت
الولايات المتحده واهمه يعني في تصوراتها
لاداره المنطقه كانت الصين بتتسلل ببطء
وهدوء
بيزيد نفودها في دول المنطقه زي كل الدول
العالم يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال امثله
كثيره جدا
انه في شهر اكتوبر اللي فات انا باخذ
الامثله الاحدث يعني في سنه 22 بس
ابو ظبي استضافت او وطنه اول مشروع لتجميع
سياره كهربائيه طبعا بتكنولوجيا صينيه
الشهر اللي سبقوا مباشره شهر سبتمبر كانت
شركه همم شركه اكسبينج الصينيه اللي شغاله
على مشروع السياره الطائره لما حبه تعمل
اول نموذج لتصورها تم اطلاقه في الامارات
نشاط شركه هواوي اللي هي طبعا يعني واقعه
تحت ضغوط وعقوبات كبيره جدا من الولايات
المتحده متغلغل تقريبا في كل الدول
العربيه رغم التحفظات الامريكيه
في تقريبا كل دول الخليج تعاقدت مع شركه
هواوي علشان تستفيد من خدمات الجيل الخامس
اللي قلنا ان شركه هواوي تفوقت فيها من
سنوات والبعض بيقول الجيل الخامس يعني
الصين يعني هواوي لكن على العموم يعني
طبعا في شركات اخرى بتقدمه في الغرب وليس
الولايات المتحده لكن اما ان هي
بتكنولوجيا اقل او على حتى لو تساوت
التكنولوجيا فالتكلفه اعلى بكثير
شركه هواوي غير ان هي تعاقد مع كل دول
الخليج على تكنولوجيا الجيل الخامس لا ده
هي كمان قطعت بقى في التعامل التكنولوجي
مع الدول العربيه مسافه طويله جدا
وتعاقدت مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
سبيل المثال اللي هي
الشريك رئيسي في اداره مدينه نيوم اللي هي
يعني اهم مشروعات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في الوقت الحالي
علشان تعرب تكنولوجيا الذكاء الصناعي ان
الذكاء الصناعي يتعامل مع محتوى عربي ثم
بدا تطور شراكاتها مع دول العربيه في
الكلاودنج او ما يسمى بالحوسبه السحابيه
والامن السيبراني بالاضافه طبعا الى
تكنولوجيا ال 5 دي
الامثله كثيره جدا لكن المساله لا تقتصر
على
مشروعات البنيه التحتيه من مطارات ومواني
وانترنت ولا تقتصر على تكنولوجيات
المتقدمه وعلوم المستقبل دي دخلت كمان في
الجانب العسكري والامني
يعني اديكم الامثله اللي كان فيها تعارض
واضح جدا ان الدول العربيه لجات للصين لما
الولايات المتحده يعني ادار ظهرها للدول
العربيه على سبيل المثال 2016 بعد اندلاع
الحرب في اليمن بحوالي سنه في 2015
الامارات توجهت للمملكه للولايات المتحده
وقتلها انا احتاج الى درونس متقدم طائرات
بدون طيار متقدمه
وكذلك طلبت السعوديه رفضت الولايات
المتحده هذا الطلب وقالت والله انا اخشى
ان انتم تستخدموه في اليمن كانت النتيجه
انه الامارات توجهت على الفور طبعا هي
راحت الاكثر من دوله لكن منهم الصين وحصلت
وتعاقدت على الحصول وحصلت بالفعل على
الدرون اللي هو من طراز وينج لونج همم
اتمنى تكون منطقه صح ولكنها درون يعني
انتشر لاحقا في عدد من دول العالم الاخرى
في 2018 تعاقدت بعد نجاح التجربه تعاقدت
الامارات على ااا وينج لونج 2 من نفس
الدرون الصيني
وبدات في استخدامها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اخذت خطوه ابعد مش ان هي حصلت
على درون صيني دي هي تعاقدت مع الصينيين
في 2017 اثناء زياره الملك سلمان للصين
على انشاء مصنع
لتصنيع السي اتش اللي هي برده طائرات بدون
تيار صينيه على ارض المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
في مجال التسليح المساله يعني توسعت جدا
يعني على سبيل المثال مثلا في فبراير ال
تعاقدت اعلان الامارات ان هي تعاقدت مع
بكين او مع الصين لشراء مقاتلاتها اللي
فيفتين ودي مقاتله للقتال الخفيف وقال
عمليات التدريب
ورغم اعتراضات طبعا الولايات المتحده
مخابرات الامريكيه كانت وما زالت تشك ان
السعوديه تعاقدت سرا مع الصين لتطويل
صواريخ بالستيه بخبرات صينيه الامثله
كثيره الخلاصه ايه الخلاصه انه
في ما يتعلق بال ما يريده الرئيس الصيني
وما يريده العرب من الرئيس الصيني وتحديدا
الدول الخليج تبدو الشراكه في هذه المرحله
شراكه مثاليه جدا يعني من وجهه نظر
الصينيين على سبيل المثال
انا
ادفع اموال للحصول على المواد الخام من
دول الخليج ثم استرد هذه الاموال مره اخرى
حين ابيع لهم المنتجات النهائيه الصينيه
فانا مستفيد جدا من وجهه نظر الدول
العربيه عندها نفس المنطق بتقول والله انا
ادفع اموال لشراء منتجات نهائيه متطوره
احتاجها من الصين لكن ما ادفعه من الصين
ما ادفعه للصين احصل عليه من الصين ايضا
حين ابيع لهم كل المواد الخام وعلى راسها
البترول والغاز الى الصين فهذا امر مريض
جدا في هذه المرحله
طيب هو مفيش تطوير ليه علاقات اخرى يعني
ما فيش اهداف سياسيه للصين ما فيش اهداف
عسكريه للصين هل ما فيش متطلبات عربيه همم
من الصين اكثر من مجرد العلاقات
الاقتصاديه طبعا في وتتطور ولكن سلوبتور
ببطء ولكن مؤكد ازاي ما هو طبيعي ان الصين
اللي هي بترفع شعار يعني اهزم عدوك قبل ان
يعلم انك تحاربه من الاصل يعني كده وفقا
لقواعد فنون الحرب اللي هم وضعها من 2000
سنه طبيعي انه لما اتغلغل في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط او افريقيا او في اسيا الوسطى
وتصبح عندي مشروعات ضخمه جدا وتعاون كبير
جدا طبيعي انه كل شيء سياتله ذلك مع
التعاضد والمصالح الاقتصاديه لابد ان يتلو
ذلك قدره صينيه على حمايه هذه المصالح
بديهي انه يكون في مصلحه صينيه لحمايه
مصالحها في منطقه الخليج وممكن يبقى في
مصلحه خارجيه النصين يلعب هذا الدور اللي
كانت بتلعبوا الولايات المتحده وقبلها
بريطانيا
بديهي انه الصين اللي هي اقتصاد رقم 2 وقد
يصبح رقم واحد وحتى وان ظل اقتصاد رقم 2
ثم انها لديها صوت في مجلس الامن حق
الفيتو يعني بديهي ان هي تستطيع ان تعول
على الصين لخدمه مصالحها السياسيه كل هذا
يحدث ببطء وسوف يحدث بشكل اكبر في
المستقبل لكن فيها هذه المرحله الجميع
يركز على البزنس ثم كل شيء قد ياتي في
وقته في المستقبل نعود الى السؤال الثاني
الذي طرحناه في اول الحلقه ماذا تعني هذه
الزياره التي تراقبها الولايات المتحده عن
كثب وتشعر بقلق شديد الاجابه المختصره جدا
الزياره هي استمرار لي سحب الصين للبساط
من تحت اقدام الامريكان في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
قارن للحضور الطاغي للصين في المنطقه هو
طاغي يعني كلمه تغذي التعبير اللي جاء في
ذهني وانا اقرا هو فيه
تقارير دوريه بتصدر عن تطورات مشروع
الحزام والطريق اللي ان شاء الله نتكلم
عنه خلال الاسبوع المقبل ان احيانا الله
التقدير ده بيقول كم دوله انضمت عدد
الاستثمارات اللي ضحتها الصين في هذه
الدول او عدد القروض الى اخره يعني اه
اجمالي الاستثمارات الصينيه او القروض
اللي قدمتها الصين تحت اا اطار او في اطار
مشروع الحزام والطريق طبقه طائت في الفتره
الاخيره لكن ظل ظلت من منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بتحصل على نصيب الاسد من هذه الاستثمارات
على كل الاحوال
حضور طاغي لانك انت لما تيجي تنظر الى
خريطه الحزام والطريق من المحيط الى
الخليج هتلاقي انه لا توجد دوله تقريبا لم
تنضم الى مشروع الحزام والطريق من النادر
ان تجد دوله لم توقع مع الصين على اتفاقات
ومشروعات بمليارات الدولار
خذ عندك كل دول الخليج البحرين الكويت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات العراق
بيحضن اهتمام كبير جدا حتى سوريا اللي هي
يعني في حاله حرب واضطرابات الصين وقعت
معها اتفاق خلال هذا العام 2022 وقود من
عندك كده همم مرورا بقى مصر بالاردن مصر
كل دول شمال افريقيا وصولا الى المغرب في
الصين عندها حضور طاغي جدا ضع هذا الحضور
الطاقي في مقابل موقف الولايات المتحده من
منطقه الشرق الاوسط من المذهل جدا انك
تقارن هذا الحضور الطاهي
دول اللي هي الولايات المتحده اللي لديها
تقريبا ازمات مع كل الحلفاء الرئيسيين في
دول المنطقه او كل الدول الرئيسه في
المنطقه طبعا هي في حاله عداء مفتوح مع
ايران ده واضح علاقتها مضطربه جدا مع
تركيا بشكل يعني يثير القلق في الولايات
المتحده وكل دول حلف شمال الاطلسي وكان في
اصوات بتضع علامات استفهام هي تركيا لسه
حليب للولايات المتحده هي لسه فعلا دوله
في حلف شمال الاطلسي
الولايات المتحده علاقتها متازمه طبعا
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه متازمه مع
الامارات
علاقات ليست مميزه مع
جمهوريه مصر العربيه حتى مع اسرائيل
العلاقه ليست في افضل احوالها اسرائيل
الحليف والطفل المدلل الولايات المتحده
رغم تحذيرات امريكا الى انه يقوي علاقاته
بالصين ويحاول ان يوازن بين مصالح بين
مصالحهم امريكا ومصالحه مع روسيا الامثله
كثيره جدا جدا لكن تندهش احنا بنتكلم على
منطقه الخليج النهارده باعتبار انه
الزياره للسعوديه
ومنطقه الخليج والدول العربيه لكن التركيز
اكثر طبعا مش دول العربيه الاخرى على
منطقه الخليج بتجد انه
الولايات المتحده علاقتها متازمه مثلا
بدوله زي الامارات اللي هي حريف قديم جدا
وهناك اتهام من المخابرات الامريكيه
وتقرير كشف عنه في شهر نوفمبر انه هناك
تحقيقات على ان الامارات بتحاول ان هي
تستخدم وسائل غير قانونيه
لتغيير او ليه تطويع السياسات الخارجيه
الامريكيه لصالحها تعمل جماعات لوبينج
بشكل من وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده يستدعي
التحقيق وهي منقعده من الامارات اللي
بتوسع علاقاتها بالصين وروسيا ضد رغبه
امريكا طبعا بالسعوديه يعني مكشوفه للجميع
وبالغت السوء ولا توجد وسيله لاصلاح هذه
العلاقات على الاقل في المدى المنظور
من الملفت جدا انه بعض المراقبين بيشوفوا
انه السعوديه مثلا في تحت بعد ما تولى
الامير محمد بن سلمان ولايه العهد اجري
تغييرات كبيره جدا على الساحه الداخليه
السعوديه كانت مطلوبه من الجانب الامريكي
من سنوات طويله يعني فكره انه يكون تقليل
الرقابه الدينيه فتح المجتمع السعودي انه
يستقبل احداث رياضيه وفنيه انه ااه يعني
كل التغيرات اللي العالم شافها في الفتره
الاخيره ديت بعد القيود الكبيره جدا اللي
كانت بتقيد حركه العمل على السيدات الى
اخره كان المتصور ان ده يكون مرض للولايات
المتحده
ويستحق الشكر من الامريكان يعني لكن ما
انفعل الامير محمد بن سلمان ذلك حتى بدا
تطرح اسئله اخرى على محمد بن سلمان وعلى
قاده عرب اخ هو هل يعقل ان احنا نبقى
علاقتنا علاقه جيده وطيبه بدوله لا تريح
حقوق المثليين هل يعقل انه همم يعني تبقى
علاقتنا طيبه بدوله لا تراعي الحريات
الدينيه لمن يؤمن ولمن يكفر وبداوا
يتكلموا على حقوق اصلا الدول الغربيه لم
تنتبه اليها الا منذ سنوات قليله الخلاصه
ان ارضاء الولايات المتحده صعب جدا على
هذه الدول
على فكره في مؤشر اخر ملفت للنظر انه
الولايات المتحده في مقابل هذا الحضور
الطافل الصيني
ليس للولايات المتحده سفراء في 40 دوله
منها السعوديه منها الامارات منها حتى
الهند دوله كبيره يعني لم يكن لها سفير
لفتره ليست قليله في مصر ليس لها سفير في
تركيا ان وضع لحضراتكم قائمه الدول
الحليفه الرئيسيه اللي ليس فيها سفير وما
فيها سفير ليه لاسباب يعني تثير الدهشه
وتدل على حاله التراجع في الامبراطوريه
الامريكيه اما لانه الاداره الامريكيه
رشحت سفيره لكن بسبب الصراع الحزب بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين لم يتم الاتفاق
او مباركه الكونجرس لهذا السفير او لانه
الاداره الامريكيه لم تجد مرشحا مناسب
فاللي بيدير السفاره في هذا البلد الحاوي
زي السعوديه ولا الامارات وتركيا وهمم
يعني بيكون قائم بالاعمال او تكون هو
السفير منتهى ولايته ومستمر في عمله ودا
يفرق
لان المفروض ان السفير اللي اختاروا
الرئيس ترامب بيعبر عن اولوياتات الرئيس
ترامب اللي هي مختلفه عن اولويات الرئيس
فايدن وهكذا
الخلاصه ان الصين بتتعامل مع دول المنطقه
كائن كقوه صاعده تريد ان تجتذب اكبر عدد
من الحلفاء بسياسه وينن وين انت تكسب وانا
اكسب فيما انه الولايات المتحده
الامبراطوريه الماذونه تريد ان تسترد
عافيتها
بستغلال الحلفاء تستخدمهم كتوك نجاح مره
وكما نصه للضرب خصومها واعدائها بقطع
النظر عن مصالحهم
اذا اردتم مثال عشان ما يكونش الكلام
انشائي ما تنظروش بس لدول الخليج اللي
الولايات المتحده بتطلب منهم امور ضد
مصالحهم النفط هو مصدر دخلهم الاساسي
والولايات المتحده بتطلب منهم ان يزيدوا
الانتاج مؤخرا حتى ولو ادى ذلك لتراجع
مستويات
الربحيه لهم لكن انظروا اصلا لحلفاء اخرين
زي الدول اوروبا اللي بداوا يشتقوا عالنا
على لسان الرئيس الفرنسي وعلى اللسان
مسؤولين اخرين في عواصم اخرى ان امريكا
تستغل الدول القاره لتحقيق مصالحها في
الحرب الدائره بين روسيا واوكرانيا على
حساب على حساب الاوروبيين وهذه القصه يطول
شرحها وسوف نتوقف عندها في حلقات الاخرى
باذن الله يبقى السؤال الاخير
هل التقارب الصيني العربي يعني استغناء من
الدول العربيه عن الولايات المتحده هذا
السؤال لا يجب ان يكون مطروحا ابدا لانه
تصريح وتلميعها الدول العربيه بتقول طبعا
انا لا ابحث عن وليه امر جديد هي بتبحث عن
شريك جديد يعزز مصالحها لا ترغب في
الاستغناء عن الولايات المتحده ولكن ترغب
في تنويع الشراكاتها وهذا امر بتعلنوا
الدول العربيه تصريحا وتلميحا وده يعني
موقف مفهومه جدا وعلى فكره الكلام ده مش
جديد
مش جديد ومنطقي منطقي لانه الولايات
المتحده حتى وان تراجع نفوذها في المنطقه
فسوف تظل دوله كبيره جدا لا يمكن دول
العربيه ان تقرر برغبتها الاستغناء عنها
ثم ان هذا الموقف قديم قديم بمعنى ان
الدول العربيه منذ سنوات بتقول للولايات
المتحده لا تغيرون بين الولايات المتحده
والصين او اي دوله اخرى نريد ان يعدد
شراكاتنا وهذا لا يعني ان نستغنى عنكم
الفكره دي يعبر عنها المرحوم الامير سعود
الفيصل وزير خارجيه السعوديه السابق من
وقت المبكر يعني في 2004 على سبيل المثال
اجرح حوار مع صحيفه واشنطن بوست وعبر عن
الفكره دي بطريقه طريفه وقال انه زواجنا
مع الولايات المتحده ليس زواجا كاثوليكيا
من وجهه نظرنا يعني انتم يا امريكان
عايزينه يكون زواج كاثوليكي بمعنى زوجه
واحده لزوج واحد لكن احنا عاوزين زواج على
الطريقه الاسلاميه
زوج واحد ربما لكن اربع زوجات ما يعني
النجمع ما بين الولايات المتحده والصين
والهند وقوه اخرى دون انفصال على الولايات
المتحده هل تقبل الولايات المتحده بذلك
هذا السؤال سوف يكون مطروح في الشهور
والسنوات المقبله ومع هذه القضيه المهمه
لكلنا حلقات الاخرى باذن الله اشكركم